hello I'm Edwin Newman one of the most
booming boom towns in world is Jerusalem
every way looks something's going up
under the pressure of immigration and
economic expansion this is true not only
on the Israeli side but in what used to
be Jordanian Jerusalem on both sides the
boom is evidence that Israel is settling
in further and what the Israelis expect
confidently expect to be permanent part
of the Middle East it is not without
significance that the larger part of the
construction force working on the boom
is arable that is true not only from the
territories Israel is occupied since the
six-day war in 1967 but in Israel itself
after a quarter of a century there is no
peace between Israel and the Arab states
but there is a ceasefire fairly well
observed and there is here and there in
the Arab world an inkling of greater
acceptance of Israel's existence still
there is also of course on the part of
many Arabs a persistent and even
implacable opposition to Israel and the
Israelis know that real peace may be a
long way off and that there may be much
trouble ahead they would be foolish to
think anything else but this is a fairly
stable and hopeful time for them and
anyone who has made periodic visits to
Israel notices that at once the world
has long since got used to the idea that
a woman is in charge of Israel's affairs
prime minister Golda Meir the fact is an
Israeli and world scene without mrs.
Meir would take a lot more getting used
to mrs. Meir has been Prime Minister
since March 1969 before that she had a
variety
of government posts and party posts she
was among other things Minister in
Moscow and Foreign Minister and at his
prime minister golda meir who will be
speaking freely today mr. mayor I wonder
whether we might begin by speaking of
Arab groups of the kind of hijacked
airplane killed Israeli athletes of
Munich it's a big deal about the
Palestinian homeland and other than the
crimes of it during and jidam see and
talk about an Arab Palestinian homeland
no I think not that any rate age for the
homeland that is referred to were
supposed to be his rayul I think it
would be worthwhile just to take a
minute the back a little bit in history
for instance between before the First
World War there were no independent down
of countries this area that is Israel
today and as a matter of fact up to the
Jordan was considered the southern part
of Syria when after the war being Great
Britain got senior mandate over
Palestine Palestine was then between the
entire area between the Mediterranean
and the Iraq Ian border
all of that was Palestine there was one
High Commissioner and considered one one
country the first partitioning of
Palestine
took place in 1922 when after the war
Great Britain saw fit to parcel out this
area of the Middle East and give part of
it to every one of the chef's who were
helpful in the war they had to do
something else or Abdullah
so they partitioned Palestine made the
western part of of the Jordan River
Palestine the eastern part is called
Transjordan 7-10 Palestine was partition
was in 47 of course now but and 1022 and
of that was one country was one
Palestine of course in the Transjordan
over this Jordan today there are Bedouin
there are others but you will not find
one single country in this area an Arab
country that hasn't various groups of
Arab people so to call to say that there
is a Palestinian people as apart from
those that are in Jordan specially this
is not true to two fact and that's true
to history now between 48 and 67 after
the war of liberation in the Western
Bank were later annexed by Abdullah they
were there I they were the majority in
Jordan if they wanted to set up a state
or to call that state of Palestine of
course it didn't have to ask our
permission and then we would have had
nothing to do with it
therefore when they say the Palestinian
people
want the right to their language what it
really means is to drive the Jews out of
this area and take over in addition to
the 19 or 20 independent Arab countries
all that have been created between the
first and second world war create one
more country instead of Israel this is
really butter smelling what what them is
the significance of the acts of terror
that we see the acts of pressure and
propaganda various kinds why then do
these people behave as they do they
don't want us here but to my sandwich
isn't only days that you're not what
they they're the people who because of
the war of 48 fled this area into Jordan
into Syria other places and have never
been resettled there is the refugees and
certainly I admit someone has to admit
it that as far that from the
humanitarian point of view there are
groups of hundreds of thousands of
people who have lived in camps for so
many years and their miserable condition
why haven't they been resettled Jordan
actually was not viable without these
people Jordan had the observation of
maybe about three hundred thousand why
when they not resettled some of them
work but generally why was there not a
resettlement of refugees of the Arab
refugees because not only the refugees
but the Arab countries themselves felt
that they should remain in their camps
he should not be resettled it was one of
the weapons against Israel military in
your measures
there's economic boycotts and one of the
methods was to keep the refugees in the
camps of feeding a hope that someday
they'll march into the country and March
us out so well they don't like us they
don't want us here our Arab neighbors to
my sorrow have not yet acquire a
logistic therefore bored and it's all
one probably that the Arabs in this area
immediate area and after that you live
in peace with us mrs. Meir it appears
from what you say that you accept that
Palestinians or whatever you want to
call them refugees have been made
victims one way or another that they
have a legitimate grievance what can be
done to meet the agreements they have
become victims to the facts that after
the United Nations in 47 decided on the
partitioning of Palestine I knew west of
the Jordan River into a Jewish state and
an Arab state we accepted and the Arab
countries did not and there was war as
imagine that there ever was a war
without refugees the difference is in
this case that the Arab people who fled
the area that became Israel afterwards
were actually one of their own people
Princeton so we Jews our a classic
nation of refugees but we were refugees
we were
among strangers with different people
who have different religions spoke a
different language is different culture
entirely different histogram one of
their own people it's the same language
the same relation the same way of life
the fact that mining was drawn to make
them any different and but that they
suffered I accept the question is was
that necessary
because during that period during these
years Israel has absorbed from the Arab
countries a much larger number of Jews
than the number of Arabs that left this
area nobody speaks of Iraqi and Jewish
refugees and in Israel or Assyrian
Jewish refugees or Moroccan Jewish
refugee hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of them and anybody that knows
the situation will agree that there was
a greater clash between European Jews
that came here or Israeli Jews who have
been here for centuries generations and
to the case of Yemen or Jesus came from
let's say the Atlas silver Morocco the
only thing that really made us one was
religious but we're Jews with one the
same nation but no common language and
some answers centuries apart in culture
and yet we absorb them and they're what
people is there anything mr. Prime
Minister that Israel can do to remove
this center of infection really a source
of infection for the whole Middle East
these Arab refugees
unsatisfied unhappy people unsettled
really because going around as I've been
doing the last few days one still sees
refugee camps of Quebec of 1948 is there
anything that Israel can do we have said
immediately after the war after the war
of liberation in 48 49 that we are
prepared to pay compensation for
anything that means that people have
left behind whether its lands whether
it's orange grove whether its houses
anything we have allowed tens of
thousands of them to come back because
families were separated during the
fighting and it's part of the families
remain here everything no problem of
security we allow them to come back now
the United Nations had a committee to
investigate but these people left behind
and do we cooperate with them it comes
up for large sums of money now if there
had been peace this money the aid from
international aid and from various
government there's no doubt this thing
would have been forgotten and they would
have been resettled in agriculture
industry or in any other way instead the
United Nations during these years for
hundreds of millions of dollars into
miserable camps we found the camps now
the Gaza Strip murder that people should
be kept in conditions of bath time but
it was done with this idea the worse the
better these people must be miserable
they must live in conditions of that
thing they must not resettle have a home
of their own or so on and so that there
would be an instrument against Israel
what about the terrorism this is mayor
Israel takes a very firm line against
terrorists against hijackers whereas
other countries do not what is the even
when the lives of others are involved
you say don't give in to hijackers what
is your reasoning we're since innocent
lives are at stake innocent lives are
always at stake the question is can
innocent Israeli lines become a
commodity that groups of men and women
can just do with them whatever they like
because when they take a plain presence
everstik see the last incident the one
that looked Angela Angela in Germany
nobody would say that it's a simple
matter for Smith but look what happened
these men demand the release from prison
of men who participated in the killing
of our people in the Olympic Village
they say and practice but they say
openly we want them out as soon as they
land in Libya they make a statement now
we'll start all over again
of course lives are involved but it
means that people are set free when
everybody knows that what they intend to
do the first opportunity we will kill
more Israelis it's a difficult problem I
don't say it's easy but Israel cannot
say well as long as it involves Israeli
it's alright
Samir is sometimes suggested that
terrorist organizations act out of a
fear of a solution being arrived at
between Israel and the Arab state is
there a prospect of such a solution a
solution between us in the atmosphere
I'm sure there is the question is when
look when was not I think look at the
situation the Middle East as though
there are Arab countries that involve
themselves in war with Israel but so it
doesn't hurt them
doesn't hurt their people their
governments carry an immense the war
budgets but the countries developed and
they have modern schooling and health
services of God but for them Israel it
suffers it's too bad about Israel but it
really doesn't matter it doesn't affect
so much the Arab country cuz that's a
distorted picture because as long as our
Arab neighbors aren't war with us
certainly they suffer at least as much
as we do as a matter of fact we have
managed great difficulties to defend
ourselves and at the same time to to
build a country which is more or less
decent more or less modern it's not all
that we wanted to happen
or that could have happened that we
didn't have to defend ourselves but
still well we were 650,000 when the
state was established there are 800,000
children in school today and we have
compulsory free education from five and
not from four to fifteen there is not
one single village in the country no
matter where it is that is out of reach
of a hospital or that there isn't a
doctor in the area and there is industry
that modern agriculture there is there a
sculpture there's music there's theater
that I mean I say it isn't all that we
want we could have done much more when
in a country like this we have a
community of close to 50,000 young men
and young women in institutions of
higher learning all this was out
practically one single month I could say
almost without one single day of peace
now this isn't exactly what happens on
the other side so war in this area is
something that is faithful to Israel and
to the others peace if it comes them
when it comes is a very important
situation for Israel they're not ashamed
to say that we want peace but also for
the other countries so anybody that is
interested in this area must not fall
into a way of thinking well there ought
to be peace because Israel needs peace
the entire area needs and the tens of
millions of people in
our neighboring Arab faith they are the
main sufferers are you suggesting them
that it is because they are suffering it
is because these countries are less
well-off and Israel is in the
particulars you've cited that there is
some hope of peace but that will create
the pressure for peace in Arab countries
yes I don't think that our Arab
neighbors will prevent us with a
presence of peace the real tragedy is
that the leaders of these tens of
millions of people of the various Arab
countries do not realign our
sensuousness for their people if they
did I think we would have had peace many
years ago this is where can you offer
any opinion any theory about the
intentions of King Hussein of Jordan at
this point well I think the positive
developments in this area as far the
neighbors are concerned that King
Hussein has come to the conclusion have
been 50 cause he's been told that there
must be a solution of peace between
Jordan and Israel and I think he said
that for all the neighboring countries
and he warmed said I believe that
another war is another catastrophe may
be a greater catastrophe for the ala
people I don't think he has come to this
conclusion for Israel's sake but you
realize is whether what it has done
introduced people and knows what is
happening in Arab countries feathers and
pooja she knows that filming and has
contact with them well that's a very
positive development the next thing that
seems to say I think has to do to
realize that since the war was brought
on Israel by his participation as well
as Egypt and Syrian so on
he cannot expect and must not expect
that everything goes back exactly where
it was before he entered the war the tax
is Jerusalem again as and grandfather
given 48 and the fact other parts of the
country when it comes to bad conclusions
then we're really on the way to peace
how far how close can I get to the
situation of as it existed before 1967
well that can only be done in
negotiations yeah you know it's a
well-known fact that Israel has
drawbacks and we don't play games with
ourselves
it doesn't that so we don't have ideas
but the basic idea is all other ideas
are based on one idea that we want peace
with our neighbors and what we want to
gain in peace territories
is not the territorial annexation what
we want is the change in territory to
the extent that is essential for us to
have borders that promise greater
security than what we have one gathers
mrs. Prime Minister that with Jordan
that would not be a great problem but
that you would for example insist on
holding the Golan Heights taken from
Syria and that that might be a much more
ticklish problem in the Jordan problem I
don't want to negotiate on a television
program no no I thought some say as the
King Hussein that she's Jordan there is
no problem because I don't think it
would be honest the practical problems I
have to see at his side of the two there
is Jerusalem not that the Jordan had any
claim of Jerusalem it was never decided
that Jerusalem were part of it it should
be Jordanian what happened in 48 was by
this breaking of this terrible principle
of the inadmissibility of conquest by
fourth we were weak in 48 Jordan was
much stronger the Arab Legion was good
are mean at that time led by British
trained by British and they took part of
Jerusalem so I don't think he ought to
get it back I am sure he won't but he
wants it back that but any rate from his
point of view it's a problem and then
again at the Western Bank you can't
expect us to restore the boundaries
where they were before so that the
against have about 12 miles between the
sea and the former border there are a
problem there are not problems that
cannot be
well I think they're all problems
between us and our neighbors can be
found why should the goAnimate
researcher a serious problem from Syria
unless they explode a again want to be
in the position where they can shell our
villages in the valley if they had had
no intention of that curve that they had
done what they did for so many years
there would have been no problem now
they want us to come down again come
down from the hill to the valley so that
they can put up their guns up above
that's that the problem this is a year
one often hears of Arab leaders would
find it very difficult to make peace
with Israel if they could not themselves
survive politically maybe survive at all
if they did make peace that thought to
be particularly the case in Egypt for
example and name another one they racked
could the man like president Sadat of
Egypt survive if he made peace with
Israel do you think is that's something
you have to think about oh I think we
all have to think about it the question
is is that I primary responsibility for
Israel what happens in these countries
of course one of the sources of the
tragedy is the regime they're not
democratic regimes dictatorship each
dictator in order to keep himself above
water promises as people various things
one of the things that every dictator in
this country promised in this area
promised their people that Israel will
be destroyed well one thing I think they
can't be blamed for that they didn't try
that they did I couldn't could not
succeed
oh maybe it's too much to expect from a
dictator that he goes back to his people
has the courage to tell them well I've
tried
we're trying you can't do it and since
you people are paying the price for it
because of illiteracy and because of
poverty and because of hunger and so on
we have to give it up live at peace with
Israel and build ourselves now if you go
on pharmacy any people that next month
is going to happen I objectively
understand that it's difficult them to
do it and maybe he's risking his being
in power maybe even his life but I'm
sorry I don't know how we can help him
mr. mayor the Russians withdrew from
Egypt at the demand of Egypt that fact
make settlement alike the prospect of
peace that will improve the prospects of
peaceful Middle East very many people
thought so we hope so but actually if
you analyze the situation we have never
said that the Russians are driving Egypt
to war against
I think for two reasons to be fair to
the Russian I don't think it's a major
point in their policy to destroy Israel
what they wanted to do is to find
themselves or to buy their entrance into
the Middle East
and the basis of feeling Nasser or any
other Arab leader what he wants salt and
in 1955 they found that what NASA wants
most is not tractors and that's modern
industrial plants and schools of thought
but he wants most is the tanks and
planes in order to destroy Israel but
there is potential differences to give
it a and kept on giving to him all the
time
now when they left we thought well if
Sadat became disappointed with the
Russians and what ground that Russia was
not giving him enough material with
which to destroy us maybe he'll make up
his mind that all right we've lost this
friend too
he doesn't believe the Americans will
help him destroy Israel maybe then he
should turn around and make peace with
it but that hasn't happened you see in
all this there's one more point that has
to be taken into consideration it's not
only because we are committed to
democracy and can't envisage a different
regime but look whether it's Israel what
is the United States any other
democratic country a government it takes
a decision which it is convinced that
it's good for the people not always
popular it goes to its Parliament
presents is
or whether the president doesn't make a
difference but says the Bobby
democratically-elected that has to deal
with it but let us take our form of
government
British form of government who the
government decides something and we go
to Parliament's attention we lose the
majority in parliament but once so there
are new elections when their new
elections either we are reelected or
another party gets into government the
state remains if we lose we'll think too
bad the others can't do as well as we do
the other party will think they'll do
better but nobody is killed and there is
no taking over by force subset or nasara
before him or Assad's in there in Syria
or the other one in Iraq they're all
they always have to take into account
that if they make a decision which is
not popular which is against the
education that they gave their people he
lose him post you over here when you're
not be president again how will he not
be present will not be reelected a few
generals or lieutenants may come in any
moment and at the point of a gun sent
him out send him words to prison or a
better place his personal life is in
danger his being president is in danger
then he was thinking and he doesn't this
is the tragic side of this kind of
regime of people dictators are supposed
to be very great people it's isn't so
because the truth they're afraid they
don't trust anybody of around them the
dearest friend
Starlin the Jewish people look how sad
Outsiders the first thing comes you did
to Jenna and I don't know how does he
take his decisions like like I do we
start the cabinet meeting today from 9
o'clock to 3 o'clock discussing
standards tell me both I don't know
whether he has gets his ministers
together and asks their advice I don't
know what he doesn't get up one morning
as well now I'll do this it doesn't so
this element which is supposed to be a
question of the risako problem what kind
of reaching of a social problem really
in a situation of this kind of validity
it's a question of life and death to
many many people other Russians coming
back in now do you think that that has
decided to have him back but look what
Sadat's did I imagine when that bright
morning he decided to tell the Russians
go home
I suppose what he thought was now the
Americans don't like the Russia so if I
send the Russians home the Americans
will applaud me and then they'll come
running in salem al president's event
you're wonderful now you send the people
we don't like away not just tell us what
you want you want us to squeeze Israel
put the gorgeous not begin to do this
afternoon well the Americans didn't do
it so he says ok as the Americans are
now involved in the political campaigns
and the Jews are so influential of
course without them there's no
president-elect of the United States so
never mind that the president's not
going to go to Western Europe here is
the place white and gets things and he
sends his messengers to Western Europe
nothing and the Americans don't help in
Western Europe doesn't help in
so now is going to scare the Americans a
little bit again
going back to the Russian it was
actually the Russians here another phase
of all this connected of course with
everything that I said before the lack
of college courage or whatever you wish
to call it of knowing that your
sovereign states a sovereign people you
have to carry the responsibility for
your decisions and for your people don't
expect somebody to do things for you
you're going to war you Egypt not so
that so it was massive as making a
difference out of the blue in 67 you
sent your army across the canal into the
Sinai desert and the Nasser said this is
the day now we're going to do it fine
you try couldn't succeed now Israel
immediately after the war said okay now
let us sit down and negotiate a peace
treaty the answer was no no no the
Americans will squeeze Israel they
remembered 56 57 the Americans and the
Russians will do it and I'll sit back
and threaten Israel the Americans don't
do it quick enough I'll start a war of
attrition and if the by lev line is not
really destroyed nevermind I'll tell my
people as Nasser good service people
two-thirds of the bar-lev line is
destroyed that's two-thirds and nothing
was destroyed you see the lack of
courage to say to the people practice of
the truth and then take responsibility
how do you Americans say do it yourself
don't expect what what if there's what
I've been saying
I'm not interested with Israel so I'm
that satisfied when President Nixon will
tell me that he will influences your
mixer must squeeze Israel does that
change mind that Israel is not
squeezable this is my ear is it implicit
of what you've been saying with the
United States out in countries of
Western Europe to whom Sadat appealed
applied after the Russians left is it
implicit what you've been saying that
they somehow missed the boat meant there
was something they could have done no
first face the with all the failures in
international life and international
relations and so on there is a certain
basis of justice honesty of decency and
when we say we're prepared to negotiate
and we say we even prepared to carry on
in direct negotiations but what what
else is expected of us what should be
expected it certainly the United States
has adopted an attitude that can't and
should not be squeezed and ice it's
prepared to help that the parties should
negotiate and I think European countries
did the same and now when Saddam went
back to Russia not sure whether he's so
happy with what he's getting from his
point of view and
very well but first he sent the money
goes back to them and I don't say that
this means us again in the near future
there will be 20,000 Russians in Egypt
but with the material that they sent
come I think all the advisors and
structures as a part of our business
they're coming back in small numbers
this is many other two points I'd like
to ask you about in connection with the
territories Israel occupied after the
six-day war one has to do with the
establishment of Jewish settlements
Israeli settlements in those areas and
sometimes it is said that Israel is
creating a fete accompli by settling in
these areas in some cases expelling Arab
farmers to do so in some cases so it has
said driving people out of their houses
to say destroying houses in life maybe
to just discuss first the question
settlement what is it you are trying to
do in the occupied territory exactly
what's the noise in parts of the
occupied territories repeting of silence
that's true we are not destroying our
houses to put up subnets we destroyed
Arab houses and the miserable refugee
camp in the Gaza Strip to widen the
roads right also for security because
there were nests of terrorists for us
for the welfare of the people at
covering up for the sewage will put the
canals that were there and setting up
other houses for them by the way putting
in electricity and water and so on now I
know people say that because we're
putting up settlements now we'll go
making it difficult for our Arab
neighbors to negotiate with us but
immediately after the war we didn't have
suddenly and we were prepared to
negotiate peace immediately after the
war now we never denied that we will not
go back to the 67 borders and we said we
want changes and certainly these
settlements represent changes in the
borders but that doesn't mean that we're
not prepared to sit down and negotiate
on the contrary we want to negotiate and
they're not oh then it's isn't as though
we come to a village we drive the Arabs
and we destroy the houses and for the
settlement Allah there is nothing
further from the truth
it may be that sometimes somebody has to
be moved a little bit not villages not
masses sometimes an individual house
they've been always with compensation
always the view buildings on fire no
we're we're not angels but without that
very well on that point mr. mayor I was
reading with little houses been
destroyed which you deny or explain I
want to say this to you because there
have been houses destroyed in the Gaza
Strip all run very true also in the
Western Bank when these houses can
necessarily that's true but had nothing
to do with their settlement there's been
no confiscation of land to give to
Israeli farmers for example that has
been written a land that was faithlyn
and if it is long to individual people
brought and paid for and if they didn't
want to accept the money now at any rate
it's at their disposal
and will prepare any moment to devote
some of the line together is Crown land
belonging to the time sighs well that's
because say thanks pal I have also read
that there have been some deportations
and to have been done some indefinite
detention without trial in the occupied
area terrorists a terrorist through some
would have been caught and action have
been put to trial and others who belong
to terrorist organizations and helped
and participated and so on so are we an
administrative less that suit less
people do not know I think to maybe
twice well knowing that with all the
terror that we have in the area
not one single attention not one single
death sentence only one or two death
services but no execution of one stand
alone
nobody was perfect that's what you see
in our civil love we did away with
capital punishment in our military court
it is allowed at the wall of treason or
something like that so that once or
twice the military court decided a death
sentence and it was always changed to
like them because governments decided in
after 67 that the death sentence should
not be required but sometimes the judges
ourself the case is so serious that
despite that they themselves decide on
death sentence but then it is all
returning to life like this mayor I want
to change the subject rather radically
I'm afraid you were born in Kiev
move the pencil went to the United
States in 1960 Milwaukee and you have
said let's weave out Milwaukee too long
to get to that lady are known as the
Meir who made Milwaukee famous because I
think he was born across from the
shuttle's family if it was AB starship
that they know what I think about but I
think for the sake of safety I'll say
both slits that pack dia red anyway
before we get to the Milwaukee part of
it you were born in Russia we went to
the United States 96 and you have said
there is any logical direction that your
life has taken desire and determination
to save Jewish children from experiences
like those you knew in Czarist Russia
how much of what lives in your memory
but the Jewish people has a very long
memory collectively and masses of
individual Jews have a symbol member a
similar memory in the United States that
there's still people of my generation
immigrant at that time this will be a
repetitious story which won't be Kiev
Senate's will be bill no land will be
cognitive big yellow sock Sibelius
Moscow it'll be just made a matter where
it will be but it's the same story the
same story the first memories of many
many Jews the first thing they remember
like is when my father and the upstairs
neighbor were nailing up the doors
because the rumors were that there's
going to be another program in Kiev it
just wasn't something that so outlandish
there were pogroms there were programs
after that at that time it did not
happen but the horror of standing there
watching what our fathers were doing and
knowing that it may happen that lived in
the lair
hearts of many people some people
despite that took the difference rose to
me this is something that as I said was
consciously or not unconsciously as well
decided my way in life do you find
yourself having anything in common then
with the Russian Jews who are now coming
closer
definitely but with all Jews why not
would choose from being Jewish children
for instance who live in the ghetto in
Syria today and know what it means to
live in a ghetto and under terror
because they're Jewish or what happened
during the Second World War and their
Hitler I mean it's the same thing it's a
question of sovereignty I have two
generations now my own that were born
here as this is one of the greatest
maybe the greatest thing in my person
requesting my personal life certainly
that I have a son and the daughter and
five grandchildren to whom what I tell
them about my childhood is a story they
know that that modern Jewish history and
ancient Jewish history but as far as
their personal life is concerned then
you know fearful the reward that's true
my granddaughter is through with the
army service now my children were in in
all the wars but no pure of apoco the
author of having to hide away about the
Russian Jews were coming here now
because that is a subject obviously that
enormous interest do you find that the
Russian government the Soviet government
responds to pressure from the outside
I'm done this is the only thing that
really can influence it and move with
all that we have to say against Russian
Albany means we have a lot to say
against the silver getting some
integration something we didn't have
several years ago now darling didn't he
couldn't have cared less what the world
thought about it or about Russia
Khrushchev was different these people
certainly are different and the
situation in Russia is such I must give
credit to be stabilities for one thing
even if it hurts me they they have a
situation in the minds of people in the
country they're desperately in need of
help in the Western world they have the
courage to go to the Western world and
ask whether trying to come to some
arrangement where they can get it
there's no doubt pressure from the West
from the world that people should may I
cannot be treated that way people the
but after what would the Jews want to
Russia they want to go to Israel they're
not going out to attack Russia it should
be allowed to do it without misery
without being sent to prison without
being sent to insane asylums without
being sent to Siberia you have any idea
how many of them want to come on nobody
has any idea and sometimes we hear from
the Russians say very few Jews want to
come out all the more reason that they
really believe that it's only very few
just to let them go and if it proves
that there are many let so many go every
three country goes back to it because
they could have had so much good will
but they let the people go and I hope
they still will come to that conclusion
what is happening now they are sending
in allowing some people to go then it
would rants from unsweet oh then some
people in central siberia
and instead of giving Goodwill they're
destroying it this mail easily a lot of
talk maybe we love guesswork about we
have sort of capacity of Israel how many
people you could actually have in this
country support how many people could
actually support themselves this is
where a current figure that the Israeli
government has in mind you know that
thing between the data bridge looking at
the mandate over Israel and the day of
end of and our independence I think
there were 20 odd royal commissions that
came so one Royal Commission once said
you can the country is so overcrowded
that you can't turn a cat a swing a cat
one of the swing cats we wanted to have
deeper into the country minute then
another Royal Commission said not one
more drop of water in this country and
of course of sort of capacity that would
be problems and dr. Weitzman once said
whether the project affects every do
that comes together Palestine in his
suitcase there's absorptive capacity for
a few more G and here we are so the
population is very very close to three
million and now we know that so much of
our country is still of cultivated and
not settled and things are developing
instead of the track of a farm of so
many acres which were necessary for a
family when we didn't have the
irrigation there were no modern methods
of Agriculture now that same cloth can
support for families and then industry
and science and technology there's no
limit really
I'd go limit we're not a people of 200
million but so the numbers that we have
we can take reserve what time mr. mayor
when you were in the United States where
you live
while but you thought of staying with
that you thought you might be an
American
Oh before I came here
Wow suppose I came there when I was
eight I became a Zionist labor zionist
be Mars correct
during the First World War
I didn't be join the labor zionist party
until I decided that I would come to
Palestine somehow I couldn't understand
the idea that I'm for a Jewish state but
AO Alma the Milwaukee so there weren't
very many years and God knows it's not
because the United States was not good
to us and it's not because I didn't
appreciate all that it had to generally
the difference between salaries and the
United States but it's because of the
Jewishness than me and because of this
peculiar streak that this you believe
something you should go and try to
accomplish it fine I'll go I live in the
United States until I was 23 King in 21
but so out of these years quite a few
number of years I was involved in
science activity all right we only have
about two minutes left mrs. Meir I do
want to ask you a bit more about past
you arrived in Tel Aviv in July 19-21
what did happen you became a teacher
that the boots but you also as I've read
picked almonds you minded chickens and
care for children you were married by
that time of course and over the years
so I've read you have never been the
beauty power you have a very limited
wardrobe
a little later you regret anything
professor must collect something which
is warm for the reveal I was not a
teacher Nike books I took care of
poultry oh and I bent the braid to
suspend washed clothes I'm a realist and
it may I suppose if I believe that if I
go to a beauty parlor I would be to be
beautiful I sold over the counter but I
knew that that won't help this is is I
have to live in it I certainly never
regretted the thing in my life I have
more joy and satisfaction in my life
then I will ever be able to tell oh and
the person in his own life she's a
revolution of this kind sees the Jewish
people the people of refugees and the
people that is either killed by some and
pitied by the rest upon people back in
its own land there are many problems and
many troubles and so on but still acting
on it so not pitied anymore at anyway
what else can a person why thank you
very much mrs. Meir okay
Golda Meir has done speedy freely Edwin
Newman NBC News